zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live bei ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen
und nachdem die impfkampagne in
deutschland ja eher schleppend
angelaufen war geht es jetzt langsam
doch richtig in die vollen
heute haben die bundesregierung und die
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
miteinander beraten wie es jetzt
weitergehen soll mit der impfkampagne es
geht da um fragen der imf reihenfolge
sollte aufgehoben werden und auch vor
allem eine frage die viele menschen im
land beschäftigt dürfen menschen die
vollständig geimpft sind also einen
vollen impfschutz genießen wieder mehr
freiheiten haben als andere als zb auch
positiv getestete oder werden die gleich
behandelt das hat die bundesregierung
zusammen mit den ministerpräsidenten der
länder heute beraten wir haben
eigentlich damit gerechnet dass die
pressekonferenz der beteiligten etwas
später los geht so gegen 18 uhr 30 aber
gerade bekamen wir die meldung die
pressekonferenz ist quasi im ja dabei zu
starten die hier den kulissen soll es
gleich losgehen wir sehen das bild hier
aus berlin und ich sehe hier auch schon
bewegung im bild da sich berlins
regierenden bürgermeister matthias
müller die bundeskanzlerin herrn söder
und ich bin gespannt was die jetzt zu
sagen haben wie man sich geeinigt hat
wir geben nach guten abend meine damen
und herren nach den beratungen über die
verschiedenen themen des impfens
informieren sie jetzt die
bundeskanzlerin der regierende
bürgermeister von berlin und der
bayerische ministerpräsident
ja meine damen und herren wir haben
heute eine ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gehabt die sich ausschließlich mit dem
thema des impfens und des der behandlung
auch der geimpften und genesenen befasst
hat und der bundesgesundheitsminister
hat uns informiert über den stand des
impfens indem wir uns einen bericht
gegeben hat und noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen hat dass wir doch jetzt im
zweiten quartal deutlich tempo gewonnen
haben
das impfen anbelangt während wir im
ganzen ersten quartal 10 prozent der
bevölkerung nur impfen konnten so sind
es jetzt in den ersten drei wochen
dieses april bereits noch mal zehn
prozent gewesen und die dinge werden
sich also deutlich beschleunigen
wir werden im zweiten quartal 80
millionen impfdosen erwarten davon sind
50 millionen von dem hersteller biontech
pfizer und pfizer zeichnet sich dadurch
aus dass hier wirklich sehr sehr
zuverlässig geliefert wird und wir
hoffen dass aber auch insgesamt die 80
millionen impfdosen eintreffen es werden
pro woche 2 25 millionen das ist ja die
absprache mit den bundesländern gewesen
dosen an die impfzentren gegeben hier
werden auch sehr viele zwei impfungen
jetzt in der nächsten zeit stattfinden
und seit einigen wochen werden ja auch
die arztpraxen geliefert jetzt im
augenblick mit ungefähr einer million
dosen pro woche das sind 65.000
ärztinnen und ärzte immerhin die sich an
dieser aktion beteiligen
in kürze werden dass zwei millionen dann
pro woche sein und das wird sich noch
einmal steigern
wir haben in vielen bundesländern jetzt
bereits die prioritäten gruppen 1 und 2
geimpft und die prioritäten gruppe 3 ist
geöffnet und im großen und ganzen gehen
wir davon aus dass in der prioritäten
gruppe 3 die impfungen die erstimpfung
im laufe des monats mai stattfinden
können so dass wir dann spätestens je
nachdem wie viele impfdosen wir bekommen
ab juli
aber ich sag nochmal spätestens die
priorisierungen aufgeben können das
heißt nicht dass dann jeder sofort games
werden kann aber dann kann sich jeder um
einen impftermin bemühen und die werden
nach maßgabe der versorgung auch gegeben
ab juni werden wir auch die gelegenheit
haben dass die betriebsärzte verstärkt
in die impfungen mit hineingehen können
es ist ja so dass die betriebsärzte
heute schon in ausgewählten bereichen
dabei sind man kann auch bei kritischer
infrastruktur dass das prioritäten
gruppe 3 schon ganze betriebe impfen die
frage ist nur wie kommen betriebe an
diese impfdosen und da müssen die
gesundheitsminister noch mal darauf
achten dass er angesichts der
unterschiedlichen sozusagen häufung oder
dichte von großen industriebetrieben in
der bundesrepublik deutschland trotzdem
eine gerechte verteilung pro länder also
pro einwohner erhalten bleibt aber das
ist ein thema das werden die
gesundheitsminister miteinander
besprechen wir der gesundheitsminister
hat uns weiter darüber informiert dass
er dann an einem digitalen ins
zertifikat arbeitet sie wissen das ist
dann auch das was in europa vernetzt
verwendet werden soll und wo er auch die
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
sich über die technischen
verträglichkeit und
vernetzungsmöglichkeiten bereits
ausgetauscht haben und dafür den rahmen
geschaffen haben
wir haben uns dann noch unterhalten über
die frage wie sieht es aus mit der
bestellung des impfstoffs sputnik 5 oder
v hier ist gibt es wird es ja keine
europaweite bestellungen geben das heißt
die bundesregierung bemüht sich selbst
für uns entscheidend ist natürlich gibt
bei der frage wollen wir diesen
impfstoff mit verwenden die frage wann
erfolgt die zulassung durch die
europäische medizin agentur
die unterlagen sind noch nicht
vollständig das paul-ehrlich-institut
ist da der rapport tür der hauptakteur
wir sind also immer gut informiert aber
die unterlagen reichen noch nicht aus
für eine zulassung
denn diese zulassung sehr bald erhalten
wird dann macht es natürlich noch sinn
dosen von sputnik zu kaufen wenn das
erst in einigen monaten der fall ist
dann werden wir insgesamt ja schon genug
impfstoff haben also davon wären dann
auch die frage abhängen wie viel wir
bei uns bestellen das war der erste
komplex der diskussion und die haben
dann als zweites einen ersten entwurf
eines papiers der bundesregierung
diskutiert über die frage wie gehen wir
mit giften genesen um hier hat sich die
situation dahingehend geändert dass das
robert koch institut vor kurzem
festgestellt hat dass von zweimal
geimpften 14 tage nach der zweiten
impfung keine relevante infektions
gefahr mehr ausgeht und das
robert-koch-institut hat auch das hat es
auch sehr lange nicht in der klarheit
gesagt gesagt genesen sind
den geimpften dann zeitgleich zu stellen
wenn entweder die erkrankung noch nicht
länger als sechs monate zurückliegt oder
aber die genesenen eine impfdosis haben
plus 14 tage für die herausbildung des
immun schutzes und dann sind genesende
den geimpften gleichzustellen
es ist evident und das hat das robert
koch institut in seiner quarantäne
verordnung auch schon deutlich gemacht
dass kontaktpersonen ersten grades die
doppelt geimpft sind und 14 tage später
keine quarantäne mehr antreten müssen
und es ist auch klar dass da wo als
zugangsberechtigung friseur click and
meet oder ähnliches schnelltests
erwartet werden
geimpfte und genesene diese tests nicht
beibringen müssen die frage was gilt
darüber hinaus und welche grundrechte
haben diejenigen von denen keine
infektionsgefahr rausgeht wieder die
haben wir heute ausführlich diskutiert
und die werden der das ergebnis dieser
diskussion wird in einer verordnung die
dargelegt zum infektionsschutzgesetz
dieser frau diese
verordnungsermächtigung ist ja im
paragrafen 28 c des
infektionsschutzgesetzes schon angelegt
die verordnung muss vom bundestag und
bundesrat beschlossen werden und wir
haben heute mit den bundesländern ein
der erste diskussion darüber geführt bei
der natürlich die frage einmal des
grundrechtsschutzes aber auch viele
praktische fragen diskutiert wurden das
war glaube ich wichtig dass wir das mal
diskutiert haben
und es ist ja auch klar dass immer mehr
dienste jetzt im augenblick haben wir
sieben prozent der bevölkerung die
doppelt geimpft sind
dass es noch ein relativ kleiner teil
aber dieser teil wird natürlich wachsen
wir werden das will ich dazu noch mal
sagen dann in eine sehr an eine
übergangsphase kommen die auch nicht
einfach ist denn wir werden immer mehr
geimpft haben aber immer noch einen
relevanten teil der bevölkerung der
nicht geimpft ist das heißt wenn wir
jetzt 50 prozent gm doppelt geimpft
haben von denen kein infektionsrisiko
mehr ausgeht und 50 prozent der
bevölkerung sind nicht geimpft dann
bedeutet im grunde eine inzidenz von 100
in der gesamtbevölkerung das für die
nicht geimpften uhr die ist ja von den
erkrankungswahrscheinlichkeit tropfen im
grunde ein insolvenz von 200 besteht das
heißt wir haben immer dann noch ein
erhebliches risiko für unser
gesundheitssystem und müssen eben auf
der einen seite gucken welche rechte
bekommen geimpfter aber auf der anderen
seite auch im blick haben es konnte ja
noch nicht jedem ein angebot gemacht
werden was bedeutet dass dadurch für die
infektionsgefahr für den noch nicht
geimpften teil der bevölkerung das wird
sich über den sommer wenn dann jeder
sein ins angebot hatte natürlich in eine
mehrheitsmeinung umwandeln und
irgendwann kommen wir an einem punkt
dass nur noch die betroffen sind die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen wir
wären ja keine 100% impfbereitschaft
haben dann ist es eine individuelle
entscheidung aber in der zwischenphase
ist natürlich eine entscheidung wo noch
nicht jedem bürger ein empfang gut
gemacht werden kann und mit dieser frage
müssen wir sehr sensibel umgehen und
gleichzeitig unsere grund rechtlichen
gegebenheiten im grundgesetz auch
beachten und das wird auch noch mal eine
erhebliche politische anstrengung seien
zwar eine gute konstruktive diskussion
für die ich mich sehr bedanken
ja ich glaube auch dass es gut war dass
wir mal die chance hatten auf einen
meinungsaustausch ohne dass wir uns
stundenlang mit seitenlangen beschuss
texten auseinander setzen müssen und
dann doch zum schluss über jeden
einzelnen satz uns beugen und versuchen
ihnen noch irgendwie anders zu
formulieren oder einen kompromiss zu
finden
das war heute wirklich ein wichtiger
meinungsaustausch zu zwei wichtigen
themen die die bundeskanzlerin eben
genannt hat und das schöne ist dass wir
alle merken dass wir jetzt beim impfen
wirklich in einer ganz anderen phase
sind als noch vor wenigen wochen der
impfstoff ist immer noch knapp gibt es
nichts drumherum zureden leider auch
immer noch knapp aber wir merken doch
wieder jetzt dynamik beim impfen
reingekommen ist und inzwischen gibt es
ja jeden oder jeden von uns geht es so
dass er jemand kennt egal ob aus dem
privaten oder beruflichen umfeld der
geimpftes und das sind auch nicht nur
ältere sondern es sind auch jüngere mit
dabei und da sieht man wie der im
fortschritt jetzt wirklich voran geht
und in allen bundesländern es ist ja so
wie auch in berlin wo wir jetzt sehr
naschen an der 25 prozent marke sind der
geimpften und daraus folgend ja dann
auch der zweit kämpften die dann
wirklich schon den kompletten impfschutz
haben also das ist wirklich gut gewesen
und dass wir heute auch noch mal vom
bundesgesundheitsminister gehört haben
dass jetzt die imf lieferungen sich
verstetigen auf hohem niveau auch
verstetigen dass wir immer mehr gerade
auch in den nächsten wochen die
hausärzte mit einbeziehen können denn
das ganze für impfen und wir sehen ja
auch an dieser stelle wie gut und
wichtig es ist dass sie mit an bord sind
dass die hausärzte jetzt mit impfen und
dann auch immer mehr impfstoff zur
verfügung haben will an der stelle aber
auch zumindest für berlin aber ich
glaube ich kann das für viele andere
bundesländer sagen deutlich machen dass
wir die impfzentren noch lange brauchen
das wird ja immer wieder hinterfragt die
infrastruktur ist aufwendig und teuer
das einladungs system ist aufwendig
braucht man überhaupt noch die
impfzentren ich glaube ja wir werden sie
noch lange brauchen sie entlasten in
vielfacher hinsicht wir haben zum einen
ja auch diejenigen die jetzt
aber zwei termine schon entsprechend
gebucht haben und dann die impfzentren
ansteuern werden um die zweite impfung
zu bekommen aber wir werden noch große
bevölkerungsgruppen haben die wir dann
auch schnell impfen wollen wenn man an
die jüngeren denkt die studierende denkt
die auszubildenden wo man dann eben auch
noch mal über die impfzentren fehler
ansprechen kann
viele die ja vielleicht auch gar kein
hausarzt haben oder das entsprechende
beratungsgespräch nicht brauchen
also insofern gerade mit mehr impfstoff
glaube ich haben auch die impfzentren
noch sehr lange ihre berechtigung wir
alle miteinander hoffen dass wir dann
mit mehr impfstoff auch wirklich die
betriebsärzte sehr schnell mit ans netz
bekommen
die werden natürlich auch nochmal für
zusätzliche dynamik sorgen was
sicherlich von großer bedeutung heute in
der diskussion war es eben der punkt wie
es weitergeht mit der verordnung zu dem
ganzen status rechtsstatus getestete
geimpfte genesene ich glaube auch hier
brauchen wir schnell eine antwort gerade
weil wir eben zum glück ja immer mehr
gelesen und vor allen dingen auch
geimpfte haben müssen wir auch antwort
geben wie wir mit den grundrechten
dieser menschen auch umgehen die
bundeskanzlerin hat das eben schon
deutlich gemacht es gibt eine klare
aussage des robert koch instituts zur
gefahrenlage sowohl für die betroffenen
selbst wie auch welche gefährdung geht
noch von ihnen aus wenn sie geimpft sind
für andere und damit müssen wir uns
auseinandersetzen wenn es so eine
einschätzung gibt dass diese menschen
doch sich sehr sicher bewegen können im
öffentlichen raum muss man darauf
reagieren also dass die bundesregierung
sich das jetzt sehr schnell vor nimmt
das thema dann der bundestag und auch
der bundesrat darüber beraten wird dass
das hoffentlich aus meiner sicht habe
ich es so im mai dann auch abgeschlossen
ist diese diskussion das war heute auch
ein wichtiger punkt in der diskussion
und das ist ja nun kein geheimnis
sondern in der letzten bundesratssitzung
auch deutlich geworden dass auch viele
bundesländer ministerpräsidenten
deutlich gemacht haben dass sie auch
sehen dass es zum beispiel bei dem thema
der ausgangssperre einen erheblichen
grundrechtseingriff gibt also dass man
sich jetzt dann damit
auseinandersetzen wie man damit umgeht
welche jenseits der normalen
alltäglichen dinge die man für die
geimpften leichter ermöglicht der
friseurbesuch oder der einkauf wie man
dann umgehen gerade mit diesen
grundrechten ganz besonders auch im
bereich der privaten kontakte das finde
ich es ja noch der sensibelste bereich
und ein ganz harter eingriff wie viele
menschen darf ich privat treffen und
dass man an dieser stelle ansetzt und
sich das genauer vornimmt welche rechte
auch mal wieder ermöglicht das denke ich
erwarten auch viele menschen jeden tag
im zum glück erwarten dass auch immer
mehr eben die die auch geimpft werden
also kurz zu machen abschließend auch
von meiner seite
dass wir heute uns erneut war ja nicht
das erste mal schwerpunktmäßig mit dem
thema impfstoff lieferung und mit allen
daran hängen dann fragen
auseinandergesetzt haben wir glaube ich
sehr gut und sehr wichtig und das haben
auch alle kolleginnen und kollegen
deutlich gemacht dass wir auch in
zukunft an diesen themen auch im rahmen
von diskussionen zwischen den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung festhalten wollen herr
ministerpräsident
wir haben eine sehr verehrte damen und
herren normalerweise wenn wir im pk
anregen mehr über einschränkungen
heute ging es eigentlich um freiheit und
freiheiten
insofern war das heute eine hoffnung sam
pk im vergleich zu den vielen vielen
apps die wir hatten
wir ringen mussten die größten schäden
zu verhindern und das sind ist klar nach
der notbremse braucht es vollgas france
info auch notbremse gegen pandemien bei
vollgas impfen
das eint uns alle der impfstoff wird
mehr an es geht es um die frage wie
können wir auch den mehr an impfstoff
noch besser einsetzen damit die wirkung
sich entsprechend entfaltet der erste
schritt ist über die impfzentren zu
organisieren war deswegen zentral
notwendig weil es dadurch darum ging im
mortalität zu senken und so große
schwachstelle die altenpflege haben wir
die über 80-jährigen ein sehr hohes maß
an lebensgefahr hatten wo wir gemerkt
mit sehr hohen todeszahlen gerade um die
weihnachtszeit herum anfang januar
dies ist gelungen ist durch impfzentrum
impfen deutlich zu senken
dort sind bayern ist instanz die über
80-jährigen die niedrigste aller
altersgruppen
das ist ein erster großer erfolg
das müssen wir stehen umgekehrt fest
dass die jünger wird die zahlen
dramatisch hoch gehen bei den 15 bis 19
jährigen haben in bayern fast 300 eher
instituts das hat sich komplett
verschoben
also muss unser ziel sein und seine
bemühungen weiter zu versuchen impfen
gegen brutalität aber auch impfen für
mobilität und der freiheitsrechte land
diesen prozess versuchen jetzt gemeinsam
zu organisieren
es gab einige länder die sehr
zurückhaltend waren auch teile der
bundesregierung dass das thema
priorisieren und betrifft es gab auch
einige andere dazu können wir die eher
glauben dass eine schnellere aufhebung
der priorisierung erfolg haben kann
warum wir glauben fest daran dass mit
dem eintritt der ärzte in im prozess die
geschwindigkeit erhöht wurden wir können
es ganz nachvollziehen
ist das eine das heißt im zehnten spiel
natürlich weiter eine zentrale rolle
aber allein das management des
einladungsmanagement ebenfalls wie
bisher ist und es ist kein fokus sondern
der tatsache führt zu müssen
zeitverzögerung bei den ärzten geht es
schlichtweg schneller
zweitens wir haben festgestellt dass
gerade in hotspots an der grenze wir
waren ja mit dem mit der britischen
mutation am stärksten betroffen
durch eine weitgehende freigabe der
priorisierung in den bereichen zwischen
volt wunsiedel und anderswo und dem
gezielten impfen mit so genannten
regionen ring impfungen also betriebe
beispielsweise nach infektionsgeschehen
hier in der entwicklung der hotspots und
deutlich verbessert
das heißt mit den ärzten kommt eine
beschleunigung ein und auch sage mal mit
einem freiheitlichen im internet nach
der strengen brüder gruppe glauben wir
dass wir die geschwindigkeit ist im fuß
und damit einen stärkeren effekt im
kampf gegen die pandemie deutlich
verstärken beschleunigen können das ist
der grund warum wir glauben und einige
an gelände auch das war an der frage
wann das geht jetzt mai oder juni das
immer dann auch noch impfstoff und
verfahren sehen aber dass das zwei hebel
sein können die wirkung des impfens zu
erhöhen
denn am ende muss man eine sind wir
haben zwei bereiche in denen wir
besonders viele herausforderungen haben
beim pandemie geschehen dass der
familiäre bereich der betrieblichen
bereich also familie und firmen impfen
familie und da sind viele möglichkeiten
das geht zum teil über ärzte und die
familien impfen
dann können sie nicht nur die strenge
altes priorität machen bei firmen
sowieso nicht weil sie können eine ganze
firma
und dann nochmal eine unterscheidung
treffen der vorteil übrigens bei den
betriebs impfungen liegt vor allem darin
dass es auch ein großes eine große impf
bewusstsein gibt denn der ganze betrieb
zum impfen geht dann schon mal gibt es
auch gewisse soziale motivation dass sie
alle dabei sind deswegen glauben wir
dass das sehr sehr helfen kann und
deswegen ist ja das thema priorisierung
und mehr ärzte starb in zentren oder
aber nicht nicht mehr sondern die
verteilung stark auf die ärzte zudem
betriebsärzte ganz ganz wichtig
zweiter punkt und der schließt dann ja
an wenn wir die geschwindigkeit erhöhen
da gab es eine debatte die war schon
sehr kontrovers muss man sagen also die
bundesregierung hat meiner ansicht nach
den richtigen oder weg dort denn wenn es
um das thema rechte für die impfte geht
es ist ja eigentlich eine absurde
debatte
jeder von uns hat grundrechte und die
geltenden gelten für jeden in der
pandemie zeit haben extra wir müssen
alle rechte einschränken
zum schutz aller inhaber des robert koch
instituts sagt dass jemand der sich
geimpft hat und der eine zweitimpfung
hat einen hohen maß an schutz bietet
dann glaube ich muss man das
respektieren und dann lässt sich
schlecht darstellen dass er die gleichen
einschränkungen hat jemand es sich nicht
kämpft hat jetzt gibt es die zeitachse
über die man muss wert haben sich impfen
lassen
aber am ende ist es für mich ganz klar
da muss es dann eben mehr möglichkeiten
gehen für diejenigen die geld ist doch
völlig absurd dass jemand der zwei mal
geimpft ist die gleichen tests vorlegen
muss wie jemand der nicht geben das ist
nicht nachvollziehbar oder ich finde
auch bmw einreise quarantäne oder
kontakt quarantäne da muss es doch
möglichkeiten geben dass sich eine
doppelte info niederschlägt außer wir
haben eine neue mutation die eine andere
gefährdung zeigt so dass die wirkung
einer impfung neu zu bewerten das so
lang ist aber nicht der fall ist das
kann nur die zuständige stelle
robert-koch-institut bzw
die medizinischen bewertungen des bundes
seien so land glaube ich ist es
notwendig da an der stelle mehr zu
machen da das leiden sich keine anspruch
sollte auf institutionen zu öffnen zum
beispiel also jemand der zwar mehr games
kann sage ich möchte dass das schwimmbad
für mich geöffnet
aber dort wo es um erleichterungen geben
kann sollte man die machen
ich denke das ist auch ein signal an die
bevölkerung ein 1 1 ein positives signal
dass sich in sloane dass sich die
bemühungen von bund und ländern lohnen
das ist auch sinnvoll sich impfen zu
lassen
und ich weiß da gibt es da die debatte
gab es dann über zwei klassen
gesellschaft und benachteiligungen sie
sehe ich aber nicht zu den eines darf
man nie vergessen rein
verfassungsrechtliche meine grundrechte
definieren sich gegenüber dem staat
nicht gegenüber mein nachbar und das ist
muss der staat als solches auch dieses
vorrecht der grundrechte bewerten ohne
dass er dabei die pandemie bemühungen
verletzt werden die notbremse gemacht
die ist richtig und die wirkt wir haben
wir erhöhen die impf aktivitäten und es
wirkt und deswegen ist die logische
folge aus diesem prozess heraus dass
wenig rechte einschränken
wo man übergang zu finden bis man
geimpft ist das dann logischerweise wenn
geimpft wird sich auch erleichterungen
geben können mit allem was die
bundeskanzlerin völlig zurecht sagte
dass es dann in zwei taxen gibt über die
man reden muss so dass ich nicht an neue
instanzen ergeben also in dem strich war
das alles heute noch kein abschluss aber
es bewegt sich sehr stark in einer
coolen richtige richtung und also ich
finde es war zu der mpk der hoffnung wir
hatten auch schwieriger mp gras muss ich
sagen und ich sind attiyah müller sagte
er weil mir nichts beschlossen haben war
es auch etwas leichter
es gab trotzdem viele wortmeldungen was
auch notwendig ist weil es einfach jetzt
auch wieder so ein prozess in dem wir
uns gegenseitig bei vergewissern müssen
aber für mich ist eines klar wir werden
corona überwinden und wir werden in den
nächsten monaten riesige schritte nach
vorn machen und das ist auch ein signal
des optimismus bei aller schwierigkeit
und alle herausforderung keiner weiß was
es an mutationen noch geben kann aber
für den stand heute finde ich kann man
sagen dass sie nach einem echt guten weg
jetzt kommen sie zu ihren fragen den
anfang macht jörg blank von dpa
bundeskanzlerin zunächst mal die frage
bei dem was herr söder auch gesagt hat
hoffnungs mpk welche hoffnungen können
sie denn den menschen ganz konkret
machen bei den hohen inzidenz das
tatsächlich schon über pfingsten
vielleicht urlaub sein wird oder
der sommerurlaub gemacht werden kann
weil darauf warten ja sehr viele leute
ist da der bundesrat von so hart dass
bis dahin schon die instanzen unter 100
sein könnten
und herr müller und herr söder wie soll
denn dann nachgewiesen werden dass ich
geimpft bin muss man dann jeweils ein
impfpass vorzeigen bei dem geschäft oder
bei bei dem restaurant oder im urlaub
danke schön aber die eine frage ist
schon sehr wichtig was ist mit dem
urlaub also wenn sie von hoffnung reden
wie weit geht die hoffnung ja also im
augenblick ist ja gerade sondern die
notbremse in kraft getreten die
bundeseinheitliche viele länder haben
aber diese maßnahmen ja schon auch
weitestgehend gemacht denn wir hatten ja
seit dem dritten märz und auf diese
notbremse verständigt die ist jetzt ja
nur noch mal bundeseinheitlich umgesetzt
und die frage wie sie wirkt hängt davon
ab wie viele menschen sich auch daran
halten das heißt auch für die
gelegenheit nutzen heute noch einmal
dazu aufzurufen
dass wir trotz aller hoffnung die wir
haben in der gegenwart noch große
probleme haben die intensivstationen
sind in vielen stellen voll zumindest
sehr sehr belastet die intensivmediziner
sagen uns dass bei den instanzen wie wir
sie jetzt haben und wir sind ja etwa
konstant oder heute wieder ein bisschen
hoch gegangen mit fast 170 pro 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen das im grunde
die gefahr einer überlastung des
gesundheitswesens nicht gebannt ist
und deshalb sind jetzt noch wochen der
anstrengung notwendig und trotzdem
konnten wir über die hoffnung sprechen
wann die empörung eintritt hängt davon
ab wie schnell wir mit der instanz
runterkommen aber wir haben gute
hoffnung dass das im laufe des monats
juni nicht anfang juni aber im laufe des
monats juni sichtbar wird und dann wird
sich die frage wie frei wir urlaub
machen können davon abhängen wie hoch
die grund instrumente ich sagte ja schon
wenn nachher die hälfte der bevölkerung
oder 60 prozent geimpft sind
juli und die 40 prozent haben die
inzidenz von 100 dann ist das mehr
als 200 und für diese bevölkerungsgruppe
sehr schwierig ich will noch einmal
daran erinnern unsere maximale incidents
im frühjahr 2020 auf denen ein guter
sommer gefolgt ist das war unter 50 und
im sommer hatten wir instanzen zwischen
zwei und vier und fünf nur damit man
weiß was für uns damals leisten konnten
da waren die hotels oft da war vieles
auf ich sage nicht dass es wieder so
weit runter gehen muss weil uns jetzt
das impfen hilft aber wenn wir jetzt
wieder darüber nachdenken können hotels
zu öffnen
das kann ich heute nicht sagen das hängt
von dem verlauf ab dessen was wir jetzt
im augenblick machen und wenn wir über
hoffnung reden nicht unterstreiche das
absolut wahre mpk der hoffnung dann
müssen wir dürfen wir die gegenwart
nicht vergessen die ist noch eine große
ernsthaftigkeit und je schneller wir
diese ernsthafte phase durchleben umso
schneller breitet sich die hoffnung aus
sie fragen nach dem nachweis oder der
kontrolle der geimpften und an der
stelle noch mal sagen herr söder hatte
es eben so formuliert es gab schon auch
eine kontroverse diskussion ja ich habe
es eher so als sorgenvolle diskussionen
wahrgenommen weil natürlich uns jetzt
auch in der debatte bewusst wurde was da
auf uns zukommt muss man ja ganz
praktisch sicher dann auch mal überlegen
wir wollen ja alle dass unsere regeln
kontrolliert werden und durchgesetzt
werden
aber wir werden dann situationen haben
dass abends auf den straßen menschen
unterwegs sind die zur arbeit gehen oder
von der arbeit kommen also völlig
richtig dass die sich dann auch in der
stadt bewegen
wir werden da hoffentlich weniger aber
wir werden dort bestimmt auch ein jahr
auf der straße haben die keinen guten
grund haben sich in den abendstunden auf
der straße zu bewegen und damit unserer
regel ja wieder sprechen und wir werden
einige haben die können sich auf der
straße bewegen und spazieren gehen weil
sie geimpft sind
das wird nicht einfach mit der situation
umzugehen und das ist eben in der
vielleicht auch gar nicht komplett
aufzulösen aber es ist eben in der
diskussion deutlich geworden dass wir
natürlich dann auch auch kommunikativ
dem begegnen müssen und deutlich machen
müssen dass regeln weiter auch zu
beachten sind um nach wie vor auch an
dritte zu schützen und um regeln auch
kontrollierbar und durchsetzbar zu
gestalten
also das war dann ein punkt in der
diskussion konkret zu ihrer frage der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat auch noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass hier ja
jetzt alle arbeiten an diesem digitalen
impfnachweis der im juni auch zur
verfügung stehen soll
wenn wir also ende mai anfang juni auch
wissen wie dann die beratungen im
bundestag und bundesrat gelaufen sind
mit der entsprechenden verordnung dann
wird offensichtlich hoffentlich dann
auch kurz danach daraus folgend dieser
entsprechenden digitale impfnachweis
möglich sein aber natürlich man wird und
einer form das auch nachweisen müssen
dass man geimpftes für die ard der ist
natürlich auch geltend und die tatsache
dass chinesen science die kann man
nachweisen durch seinen positiven pcr
test also der positive pcr test ist
praktisch der nachweis dafür dass sich
die krankheit hatte und wenn das länger
als 28 tage zurückliegt dann es gilt man
als genesen und wenn die sechs monate
seit dem positiven pcr-test verstrichen
sind da muss ich noch eine zusätzliche
impfung plus 14 tage aufweisen damit ich
gewesen bin
für die ard kerstin holze frau
bundeskanzlerin bleiben sie bei ihrem
bei ihrer zusage ihrem versprechen dass
wir alle bis zum 21 september ein
impfangebot bekommen sieht es momentan
aus ihrer sicht da danach aus und eine
andere frage an herrn söder
wann und wie konkret werden sie in den
wahlkampf der union eintreten
ja ich kann ganz eindeutig nach den
jetzigen angaben sagen dass jedem bürger
in impfangebot gemacht werden kann
das setzt natürlich voraus dass die
impfstoffe wirksam sind also dass keine
mutationen auftreten wo die impfstoffe
nicht mehr wirksam sind aber von der
zahl der uns zugesagten impfstoffe
können wir bis ende des sommers 7 ein
empfang gebot machen ja also unabhängig
von der tatsache ist es heute
überraschender weise nicht beratungs
gegenstand war
also haben uns nicht über wartung
unterhalten als vorsitzender der
christlich sozialen den jungkönig runde
die uhren einsatz für den erfolg bei der
bundestagswahl
ob in bayern oder darüber hinaus und
sonst dann halt jeweiligen planung
gegeben da ist noch nichts abgestimmt
aber nicht mehr auf jeden fall mein
beitrag erbringen
andreas linke schon heute frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben es immer von
impfstoffen geräte aber es gibt ja
verschiedene impfstoffe und deswegen
stellt sich die frage gerade bei den
einreisen
ob damit auch impfstoffe gemeint sind
die in europa noch nicht zugelassen sind
es gibt ja auch eu-staaten die sputnik
zum beispiel verhelfen gelten für die
damit geimpft sind dieselben regeln wie
für piontek oder astra zenica geimpfte
dass die eine frage und eine kurze
nachfrage an herrn söder zu dem thema
sputnik wenn die kanzlerin jetzt sagt
dass der bund sich um die sputnik
beschaffung bemüht wird bayern dann
seine bemühungen erst einmal
zurückstellen
also wir haben noch keine ganz
abschließende meinung dazu das ist noch
eine internationale diskussion
es gibt ja im grunde die zulassung bei
der emea die für uns sehr wichtig ist
also für uns als mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union
und dann gibt es die zulassung der
impfstoffe bei der whu und die
chinesischen impfstoffe zum beispiel
haben jetzt beantragt bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation auch eine
anerkennung zu finden und ich denke dass
die anerkennung bei der whu schon ein
wichtiges signal sein müsste um eine
internationale anerkennung von
impfstoffen auch zu bekommen aber eine
ganz abschließende meinung dazu ist noch
nicht erfolgt
wir koordinieren und dann kommen wir zur
letzten frage michael kufner deutsche
welle eine frau bundeskanzlerin ich
wollte konkret fragen ob sie sich heute
über indien unterhalten sowohl was
mögliche konkrete hilfe mit impfstoffen
womöglich angeht aber auch die doch
recht komplizierten internationalen
lieferketten was die situation dort für
sie bedeuten könnte und ganz kurz an sie
alle drei die frage was ist das oberste
gesellschaft ziel ein
über ein jahr nach beginn der pandemie
hier in deutschland also wir haben uns
kurz über indien unterhalten einmal über
die frage ob die dort aufgetretenen
mutationen auswirkungen auf unsere
impfstoffe haben das können wir zurzeit
noch nicht sagen
das wird aber natürlich mit hochdruck
untersucht und wir haben aus
vorsichtsmaßnahmen jetzt ja die also
indien zum hoch risiko oder nein zum
mutations varianten oder varianten
gebiet erklärt also zur mutations gebiet
das heißt es können nur noch menschen
mit ständigem wohnsitz in der
europäischen union und insbesondere
deutsche staatsbürger einreisen und die
auch nur mit einem negativen tests und
einer verpflichtenden quarantäne
das heißt das wird den reiseverkehr mit
den iren sehr stark einschränken und wir
setzen uns auch dafür ein dass dies eine
europaweite regelung wird denn sonst hat
man ja die gefahr dass über die transit
reisen die schweiz da ist das ja auch
passiert doch zu viele solche mutationen
nach europa kommen
und was ist das oberste
gesellschaftliche ziel naja wir das
oberste gesellschaftliche ziele es allen
menschen alle lebensmöglichkeiten
spricht grundrechte und alle nutzungen
ihrer bekannten lebensmöglichkeiten
schnellstmöglich wieder zu geben also
die einschränkungen möglichst gering zu
halten denn das was jetzt die über ein
jahr andauernde pandemie jedoch an
gesellschaftlichen wirkungen mit sich
gebracht hat das ist ja ohne beispiel
seit ende des zweiten weltkriegs so
etwas kannten wir nicht und wir haben
uns jetzt sozusagen in dem täglichen
bekämpfen dieser pandemie ja alle
unglaublich engagiert aber wenn man sich
manchmal neben das geschehen stellt und
überlegt wie sah die welt vor zwei
jahren aus dann wird uns ja erst
schmerzlich bewusst was wir alles an
einschränkungen und an beschränkungen
haben
global und auch sonst und das ist schon
gewaltig also so schnell wie möglich
wieder zu einer lebensweise zurückkehren
aber das wird so schnell nicht gehen
deshalb haben wir jetzt ja auch schon in
der europäischen union für 22 2022/23
impfstoffe bestellt wir werden nach
impfen müssen wir werden mit diesem
virus noch eine ganze weile leben müssen
aber trotzdem so viel wie möglich
normalität und vor allen dingen nicht
nur uns impfen sondern auch den rest der
welt empfinden wir sehen ja wenn
woanders die mutationen entstehen dann
beeinflusst uns das auch mit was die
lieferketten angelangt da will ich heute
jetzt gar nicht weiter darüber sprechen
wir werden internationale lieferketten
auch in zukunft haben wir werden aber
auch gucken dass wir eigene
produktionskapazitäten haben wie der wii
ja der impf starb dem wir in der
bundesregierung gebildet haben auch
erarbeitet und wir werden mit anderen
ländern aber auch gut zusammenarbeiten
und vor allen dingen wenn wir jetzt
erstmal gucken dass wir indien helfen
können da wird jetzt mit hochdruck daran
gearbeitet
inwieweit gesorgt doch produzierende
anlagen dort hinbringen können ganz
europa macht dass ich habe heute auch
mit dem portugiesischen
ministerpräsidenten der jetzt ja die
ratspräsidentschaft innerhalb darüber
gesprochen und wir wollen alles tun um
indien zu helfen gesellschaftliche ziel
ist doch eigentlich vom ersten tag an an
größtmöglicher internationaler
solidarität die für uns alle auch
verzicht bedeutet so viel wie möglich
leben zu retten
das ist doch worum es geht vom ersten
tag an und ich ergänzen und wir hätten
gerne wieder unser altes leben zurück
dankeschön noch einen guten abend
in die einzelnen soweit also die
pressekonferenz von bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel berlins regierendem
oberbürgermeister müller als
vorsitzenden des ministerpräsidenten
gremiums und bayerns ministerpräsident
söder da ist meine kamera und dass der
kollege thomas reichert einen schönen
guten abend thomas hallo du hast das
ganze gerade mitverfolgt die erste frage
an dicht ist die klassische frage gab es
da jetzt irgend welche überraschungen
aus seiner perspektive ganz große
überraschung der wisse nicht insofern
auch heißt es ja eben ein beratendes
treffen war der ministerpräsidenten
deswegen ging es jetzt noch schneller
fertig als bei den letzten als sie zu
einem ergebnis kommen mussten es geht ja
um eine änderung dieses
infektionsschutzgesetzes das ist in der
ersten sache eine sache des bundes die
ministerpräsidenten haben sich als
beraten
bemerkenswert waren schon zwei punkte
vielleicht erstens merkel hat klar
gemacht dass die improvisieren
wahrscheinlich oder hat das versprechen
gegeben dass die im juni aufgegeben wird
dass ich dann also im juni dann
tatsächlich auch jeder impfen lassen
kann und ein zweiter punkt war
interessant dass es offenbar trotz
dieser beratenden sache streit gab
zwischen dem ministerpräsidenten und den
minister und zwar sogar innerhalb der
parteien also auch innerhalb der spd zum
beispiel zwischen dem niedersächsischen
ministerpräsidenten wein und der
justizministerin lamprecht da geht es um
eine knifflige frage die uns in den
nächsten wochen vermutlich sehr
beschäftigen wird was bedeutet es wenn
leute genesen sind vom kopf wenn sie
geimpft sind welche rechte sollen sie
zurückbekommen
im gegensatz zu denen die eben noch
nicht geimpft sind das ist ein
strittiger punkt noch das hat auch süden
der pressekonferenz noch mal deutlich
gemacht wie man damit umgeht da hat
diese mpk es noch keine richtige lösung
gefunden
thomas bevor wir weiter sprechen möchte
ich mich kurz mal wieder an die
zuschauerinnen
richten insbesondere auf youtube geht es
gerade ich sag mal ein bisschen
unzivilisiert her
es wäre wirklich schön wenn ihr euch
miteinander einigermaßen sachlich
auseinander austauschen könnte und
einigermaßen zivi miteinander werd ich
kann ja verstehen dass es um gut geht
ich glaub nach 14 monaten pandemie
liegen die nerven bei vielen leuten lang
bei mir privat tatsächlich auch also ich
kann das nachvollziehen trotzdem hilft
es nichts sich im internet gegenseitig
an zu schreien das kann ich auch aus
meiner erfahrung euch sagen lieber zum
hass es gab ja ein eckpunktepapier von
der bundesregierung dass am wochenende
auch schon in den medien war
was stand denn da drin und ja warum ist
denn das nicht heute schon beschlossen
worden
also zunächst mal vor mal die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist nicht
das gremium wo dieses eckpunktepapier
beschlossen wird es geht da um
änderungen und ergänzungen zum
infektionsschutzgesetz das ist den
bundestag und dann eben auch im
bundesrat beschlossen werden
aber das ist ein gesetz das da ergänzt
werden soll gesetze werden nicht in eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
sondern eben im bundestag die dafür
zuständig ist und deswegen ist das alles
eben heute eine der raten der sitzung
dafür aber hätte er trotzdem irgendwie
übereinkommen können dass man das was da
drin steht irgendwie gut findet dass das
auch durch den bundesrat und schnell
durchrutscht da muss man ja die
verschiedenen hürden nehmen das scheint
ja nicht der fall gewesen zu sein
frau merkel hat gesagt man hat sich
ausgetauscht bei herrn söder habe ich
ein bisschen gehört es gab auch knatsch
genau diesen diesem söder knatsch das
ist glaube ich ein zentraler punkt um
den es da geht also grundsätzlich kann
man doch ich sagen es gab schon eine
große große einigkeit deswegen wahnsinn
wie gesagt hat so schnell fertig aber ja
es gab eben genau bei der frage wie soll
dieses infektionsschutzgesetz angepasst
werden
pro monat bedeutet ja dass uns allen in
der bevölkerung richtigen namen wurden
freiheitsrechte die wir sonst
selbstverständlich haben wie eben abends
auszugehen
die wurden uns genommen um die um die
pandemie einzudämmen um das um den
grundrechts auftrag der regierung
nämlich leib und leben seiner bürger zu
schützen um das wahren zu können
und jetzt gibt es eben gelesen und
geimpfte von denen das
robert-koch-institut sagt von denen geht
keine infektionsgefahr aus und somit
gibt es eben auch
ein grund mehr ihnen jetzt diese
grundrechte zu entziehen und das
bedeutet zum beispiel das war einer der
punkte in diesem eckpunktepapier das
gelesene und geimpft gleichgestellt
werden mit solchen die kurz zuvor
negativ getestet wurden das bedeutet sie
können ohne weiteres wie sollen wurde
weiteres dann zum beispiel klicken mit
einkäufe machen können sie sollen dann
auch ohne vorherigen test zum friseur
gehen können wo wir zusagen nicht
geimpft die kurz vorher noch einen test
machen müssen damit das möglich ist also
im grunde geht es darum in diesem papier
das genießen und geimpft
die rechte bekommen die im moment in dem
film fiktion schutzgesetz jene haben die
gerade erst getestet wurden oder einen
test von 24 bis 48 stunden vorweisen
können
aber ich verstehe es richtig herrn söder
geht es nicht weit genug
markus söder hat hat deutlich gemacht
etwas was auch andere
ministerpräsidenten gesagt haben wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass eben diese
rechte die wir den leuten suchen haben
die ihn zurückgeben müssen wenn sie
keine gefahr mehr sind dass er deutlich
gemacht hat und was eine nach wie vor
offene frage ist ist so der hat gesagt
das bedeutet nicht dass geimpfte oder
genesene bei ihrer kommune einklagen
können dass sie ins freibad gehen können
während alle anderen davor der tür oder
vor dem tor noch stehen oder dass sie
allein in museen gehen können das gilt
museen nur wegen ihnen öffnen müssen
das ist in der tat ein punkt den süder
gemacht hat aber ob er wirklich so
zutrifft das ist eine andere frage
das gesundheitsministerium in baden
württemberg hat kurz vor dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz einen brief
an das gesundheitsministerium
geschrieben wo sie darum dringend
aufklärung bitten
es gibt klagen baden-württemberg zum
beispiel von einem betreiber von
ferienwohnungen gesorgt
ich würde gerne meine ferienwohnungen
nur jene vermieten die geimpft sind
was spricht dagegen und die baden
württemberger baten dringend
argumentationshilfe weil sie sonst
fürchten dass in der tat
verwaltungsgerichte dann so entscheiden
dass sie sagen ja einem
ferienwohnungsvermieter ist es nicht zu
untersagen wenn er explizit nur an gft
vermietet also in dieser folge dieses im
fortschritt den wir jetzt ja endlich so
ein bisschen erleben ergeben sich eine
reihe von praktischen fragen die ganz
schön knifflig sind und die natürlich
auch gesellschaftlichen sprengstoff in
sich hatten war jesus oder war es
naheliegend ist dass die leute dann auch
sagen warum dürfen die das was ich nicht
darf weil ich hatte ja doch gar nicht
die gelegenheit oder die chance nicht
ebenfalls zu lassen
das ist toll knifflige fragen haben wir
heute auch von euch hoffentlich also
wenn ihr fertig seid euch gegenseitig zu
beschimpfen könnt ihr uns gerne
konstruktive fragen schicken
zum beispiel an professor steffen
augsburg zu den werkstätten thomas das
sind gleich wieder bei dir
aber da ist professor stefan augsburg
mitglied des deutschen ethikrates und
professor für öffentliches recht an der
uni gießen
jetzt haben wir gerade schon eine ganz
konkrete frage gehört ja also die können
wir daher besprechen wenn ich geimpft
bin oder wenn wir aus diesen ferien
wohnungsanbieter haben er sagt mein
business liegt seit einem jahr flach
jetzt gibt es geimpfte an die möchte ich
vermieten und das klagen sehen sie da
eine chance dass dieser vermieter recht
bekommt aber durchaus wir müssen an der
stelle dann unterscheiden einerseits
zwischen den grundrechten des vermieters
der daraus der einkünfte erzielen möchte
und andererseits auch den grundrechten
diejenigen die diese ferienorte wohnung
nutzen möchten
beide können sich mit guten gründen
darauf berufen dass durch personen die
bereits geimpft sind oder genesen sind
eine deutlich geringere
ansteckungsfähigkeit oder ansteckung
droht als durch die normalbevölkerung
und wenn das so ist das hat dieses
eckpunktepapier finde ich völlig zurecht
und eigentlich aber auch wenig
überraschend da mal hervorgehoben
dann entfällt der zentrale grund für
beschränkungen die andere frage ist ob
man tatsächlich auch gegenüber
staatlichen stellt das war ja die
perspektive mit museen und mit
öffentlichen schwimmbädern oder so ob
man demgegenüber einklagen kann dass man
sie nutzen kann das mag man noch mal
anders beurteilen aber wenn es darum
geht dass private etwas öffnen wollen
für andere private die geimpft
sind unter chinesen sind dann ist das
mit sicherheit etwas was man einklagen
kann und wo ich auch glaube das ist auch
wenn es vereinzelt ich glaube jetzt
zuletzt eingreifen sollten gegen
stehende entscheidung gab eigentlich
sehr gute chancen mit haben müsste warum
gibt es dann unterschied also im
endeffekt ist es doch sag mal für die
gesellschaft und für eine
infektionsgeschehen unwesentlich ob ich
mich in den privaten raum befinde oder
in der gastwirtschaft zum beispiel oder
einem öffentlichen raum der sicherheit
nur von anderen betreibern betrieben
oder java unterstellen wir mal es gibt
eben in der stadt nur den einen
geimpften der das museum in anspruch
nehmen müsst möchte dann können wir
nicht dem einen anspruch geben dass
allein um seine des vergnügens willen ja
es ist verständlich dass man wieder ins
museum möchte aber das allein
seinetwegen das museum wieder geöffnet
werden muss das heißt da brauchen wir
irgendwie schon eine kritische größe
wenn es um öffentliche infrastruktur
geht da haben wir auch tatsächlich mehr
freiraum für die staatlichen instanzen
das zu entscheiden
aber wo das bereits zur verfügung
gestellt wird also wo wir private haben
die sagen wir wollen das öffnen und wo
wir gekämpft oder genese haben und sagen
wir wollen das nutzen da sollte das auch
geschehen
der ethikrat war vor einigen wochen noch
zu einer anderen ansicht gekommen da
habe ich mich auch hier mit ihrer
vorsitzenden professor aline bicks
unterhalten und habe sie ein bisschen in
die mangel genommen weil damals es auch
hieß das können wir noch nicht
befürworten dass menschen die geimpft
sind andere rechts oder die ihre
freiheitsrechte ihre grundrechte
zurückbekommen hat sich das jetzt
geändert durch die einschätzung des
robert koch instituts ja wir haben das
im ethikrat tatsächlich schon seit
längerem und auch kontrovers diskutiert
werden im vergangenen jahr eine
stellungnahme zu immunität nachweisen
veröffentlicht wo wir tatsächlich
ziemlich hälftig geteilt waren in der
wahrnehmung wie das gestartet werden
sollte oder eben noch nicht gestartet
werden darf bei den bescheinigungen
haben wir auch darüber gestritten und
haben uns dann allerdings nicht dazu
durchgerungen zu sagen das geht nicht
sondern haben gesagt wer das hängt
natürlich von den erkenntnissen ab also
wir haben eine idee desto formel hinein
genommen und gesagt je mehr wir wissen
je sicherer als ist dass die
ansteckungsfähigkeit tatsächlich
signifikant reduziertes desto eher muss
man dazu kommen die freiheitsrechte
wieder in vollem umfang denjenigen zu
gewähren
nicht mehr entsprechend ansteckend sind
und wir sind ein wenig unserer zeit
diesbezüglich voraus gewesen wenn man so
will dann kurze zeit später kam
tatsächlich entsprechende recht gut
belegte erkenntnisse erst aus studien
aus dem vereinigten königreich später
dann auch die bestätigung durch das lka
dass tatsächlich die
ansteckungsfähigkeit bei den geimpften
sehr stark abgesenkt ist und
dementsprechend passt das glaube ich
voll zu unserem papier zu sagen wir
müssen dann jetzt auch diese
freiheitsrechte den geimpften und auch
den genesenen wiedergeben aber das ist
eine diskussion die jetzt gerade hier
tatsächlich in den kommentaren sehr hoch
her geht wo sich viele userin user
beschweren das führt zu einer
zweiklassengesellschaft wenn ich mich
aus welchen gründen auch immer nicht
impfen lassen möchte sei es weil es mir
zu unsicher hieß es solche kommentare
haben wie hier auch das können wir
gleich mit eva hungers besprechen die
ist mitglied bei der ständigen
impfkommission des robert koch instituts
und kann muss dazu sicher noch mal was
sagen aber wenn ich das nicht möchte aus
irgendeinem grund da habe ich ja die
freiheit eine impfpflicht soll es nicht
geben rennen wir dann nicht nur
zwangsläufig in eine
zwei-klassen-gesellschaft
also ich würde zum einen erst mal sagen
wir haben natürlich jetzt eine
klassengesellschaft schon bei 119
wir haben massive soziale unterschiede
die wir viel zu wenig beachten wenn wir
über die entsprechenden auswirkungen der
pandemie sprechen also ist die
zweiklassengesellschaft nichts was erst
durch die impfung entsteht sondern durch
die infektion als solche und zum anderen
ist es aber auch gerade war den
impfungen so dass die ja zunächst mal
eine gute normativ begründete
priorisierung haben die ihnen zugrunde
liegt das habe ich das erste mal kurz
erklären was eine normative priorisierte
begründer ja die wir haben
wir haben die begründung für die risiken
auf und reagieren darauf und wenn dann
nachdem sie diese impfung haben davon
auch vorteile für sie ausgehen dann ist
das glaube ich keine inakzeptable
situation und werden wir zu einem
anderen zeitpunkt das glück haben dass
alle die wollen sich impfen lassen
können
das ist ja etwas was jetzt jedenfalls in
greifbare nähe rückt dann haben wir auch
keine inakzeptable benachteiligung denn
dann ist es ja meine ganz persönliche
entscheidung ob ich das in kauf nehmen
oder nicht na ja das hab ich habe hier
ein kommentar ich habe ja argument das
passt ganz gut von den news
wo ich den usernamen gerade nicht mehr
weiß tschuldigung ich habe es mir kurz
notiert der kommentar geht in richtung
warum muss man sich grundrechte er
impfen also zurückkämpfen grundrechte
wurden zum schutz der gefährdeten
entzogen
diese sind aber jetzt doch geschützt
also in gruppen 1 und 2 die akut
gefährdeten wo wir hohen
sterblichkeitsraten hatten die sind
geschützt also ist das argument in die
richtung sorry dann könnt ihr mir nicht
die grundrechte weiter entziehen weil
das war der grund dass ihr die sie mir
entzogen habt ja das ist in der
ausgangssituation natürlich richtig und
ich glaube daran ist auch wichtig zu
sehen dass wir alleine mit der insolvenz
wahrscheinlich kein gutes kriterium
haben aber gleichzeitig sehen wir
natürlich auch das jetzt in der dritten
welle anders als in der ersten und
zweiten offensichtlich die
altersstruktur der auch schwereren fälle
sich verändert hat
das heißt anders als früher sind es
jetzt vielfach menschen die mitten aus
dem leben reißt die auf die
intensivstation behandelt werden müssen
und insoweit können wir glaube ich nicht
mehr ganz einfach sagen wir haben ja
alle verletzlichen entsprechend schon
geschützt wir müssen uns sicherlich
darüber gedanken machen welche risiken
wir bereit sind hinzunehmen
das hat aber nichts damit zu tun dass
diejenigen die geimpft sind die
freiwillig sich haben impfen lassen
bereits jetzt einen anspruch darauf
haben dass ihnen gegenüber die
beschränkung zurückgenommen werden das
eine schließt das andere überhaupt nicht
aus die tatsache dass man gegenüber den
geimpften und den genesenen bereits die
beschränkung zurücknimmt bedeutet ja
keineswegs das zwingend die gegenüber
den noch nicht geimpften auf alle zahlt
irgendwie in kraft bleiben und ganz
wichtig ist auch der punkt den sie
hervorgehoben haben der auch natürlich
hier schon zur sprache kam wir müssen
auch immer die tests strategie mit in
den blick nehmen wir werden auf
absehbare zeit ja auch personen haben
die aus bestimmten gründen nicht nur
aufgrund einer individuellen
entscheidung sondern aufgrund auch
irgendetwas gesundheitlichen oder
stimmten im zweimal schoss gründen bei
kindern sich noch nicht impfen lassen
können
denen müssen wir eine alternative
anbieten und da spielt die tests
strategie eine ganz große rolle
aber wenn sie gerade sagen die
grundrechte können ja nicht auf ewig
entzogen werden also ich gehe jetzt mal
an kommentaren kann man sagen warum
zweite idee der ist ich würde mal sagen
mindestens polemisch wenn ich stark
übertrieben aber das ist am gerade hat
es ist ein bisschen der der
dass der sound den wir hier im chat
haben vielleicht guckt ihr könnt ihr mal
kurz auf meinen rechner schalten
da kann es schon aus dem usernamen sehen
dass der- oder diejenige kein großer
freund ist von diesen maßnahmen der
account nennt sich mobiles gift impf
giftspritzen kommando und schreibt also
ungeimpfte werden nie wieder ihre
grundrechte zurück bekommen sollen sie
dann abgeschoben werden eingesperrt
werden oder sollen sie exekutiert werden
also ich denke das ist mindestens
polemik aber tatsächlich schwingt da ja
die befürchtung mithin ich möchte mich
nicht impfen lassen und kriege dann nie
wieder meine grundrechte wieder ist kann
ja auch nicht sein
nein und das ist glaube ich auch
wirklich unglückliches beispiel für die
polarisierung der debatte die wir auf
beiden seiten erleben
es hat wenig sinn wenn wir einander nur
die mit mit den schlimmsten vorwürfen
begegnen und gewissermaßen die einen den
anderen unterstellen sie würden auf
gräbern tanzen oder eben giftspritzen
beides ist evident falsch wir müssen
versuchen die grauschattierungen stärker
in den blick zu nehmen und zu erkennen
das ist eben nicht nur so schwarz weiß
kategorien gibt und deshalb ist es auch
wichtig zu sagen dass natürlich die
ungeimpften nicht dauerhaft ihre
grundrechte vorenthalten kommt es wäre
geradezu absurd die ungeimpften
profitieren davon dass sich ein großer
teil der bevölkerung impfen lässt wenn
wir es erreichen dass ein großteil der
bevölkerung geimpft ist dann wird es
selbstverständlich sein dass wir zu dem
punkt kommen wo wir sagen jetzt kann das
für alle aufgehoben werden auch das ist
übrigens etwas was immer schon klar war
dass wir versuchen müssen diese so
genannte herdenimmunität zu erreichen
also nur durch impfung oder eben eine
durch immunisierung der bevölkerung zu
erreichen damit wir dann entsprechend
nicht mehr das risiko einer sich
exponentiell verbreitenden infektion
haben also werden die nicht geimpften in
gewisser weise von denjenigen
profitieren die sich haben impfen lassen
das muss man den radikalen impfgegnern
vielleicht immer noch mal vor augen
halten dass sie damit in gewisser weise
sicher auch unsolidarisch verhalten
demgegenüber die da mitmachen und
umgekehrt das ist schlecht so das ist
natürlich nicht nur sagen wir mal
gesundheitliche körperliche vorteile mit
sich bringen kann wenn man sich impfen
lässt sondern das ist auch
schlicht auswirkungen hat auf die eigene
gefährlichkeit und daran knüpfen die
infektionsschutz maßnahmen nun einmal an
wir haben statistisch gesehen ein sehr
kleines risiko dass wir tatsächlich
infektiös sind andere anstecken können
wenn wir aber geimpft sind oder genesen
sind dann ist dieses vergleichsweise
geringe statistische risiko noch einmal
signifikant abgesenkt und darauf müssen
wir reagieren indem wir entsprechend
freiheitsrechte wieder in vollem umfang
oder jedenfalls in ansatzweise vollem
umfang zurück gewähren das was da heute
beschlossen oder wie er betont wurde
nicht beschlossen wurde ist insoweit ein
sehr sehr vorsichtiger schritt also herr
söder sprach von der mpk der hoffnung es
ist eine sehr sehr kleinteilige
herangehensweise die wir da erleben wir
reden seit langer zeit über die
erforderlichkeit von entsprechenden
differenzierung und wir ihnen auch seit
langer zeit darüber was das unter
anderem technisch voraussetzt dass da
jetzt erst über die entsprechenden
nachweise nachgedacht wird ist auch
etwas unglücklich
wir haben eine verpflichtung aus
verfassungsrechtlichen und aus ethischen
gründen daraus dass wir die menschen
nicht länger als unbedingt nötig in
diesem zustand relativ warum freiheit
behalten so dass wir jetzt eine lange
differenzierte antwort auf eine sehr
differenzierte wortmeldung es gibt jetzt
hier auch schon beschwerden dass sich
die raus besucher ist notiert aber
tatsächlich muss ich ja sagen gibt es
diese hier und das können wir nicht
komplett ausblenden dass es eben ja
diesen dieser art ist des kurses gibt
und ich finde auch richtig dass sie das
kritisieren aber wenn wir jetzt mal
tatsächlich in ihrer funktion als
mitglied des ethikrates kurz mal
diskutieren dann habe ich mich gerade
gefragt also da gibt es jetzt menschen
die wollen sich nicht impfen lassen aus
welchem grund auch immer gesundheitlich
oder tatsächlich weil sie angst haben
oder weil sie sich in ihren bettchen
verschwörungs erzählungen venen und
meinen sie würden damit dann verfolgbar
dann kammer ist es ethisch vertretbar
dass man sagt okay diese vielleicht 15
20 prozent profitieren davon dass der
rest sich impfen lässt und sagt einfach
ok macht ihr mal ich warte bis der
schutz wieder da ist ja ich halte das
auf jeden fall für ethisch vertretbar
denn die alternative wäre eine
zwangsimpfung einzuführen und dafür gibt
es dann wahrscheinlich keine begründung
jedenfalls müssen wir doch im moment
davon ausgehen dass wir hinreichend
die personen finden werden die
freiwillig mitmachen an der impfkampagne
aber wir haben oder in den familien
schon zwangsimpfungen für verschiedene
krankheiten in deutschland wo gesagt
wird wenn du keinen ich glaube kein maß
an schutz nachweisen kann es kein mit
windpocken schutz nachweisen kannst
kannst du zum beispiel nicht in einem
öffentlichen kindergarten gehen und der
deutsche ethikrat hat sich kritisch zu
diesen masernimpfungen geäußert hat also
vorstellen dass man da ein anderes etwas
differenziertes konzept verwendet in der
tat ist es so dass wir mit mit
zwangsmaßnahmen immer sehr vorsichtig
sein
wir haben im moment glaube ich glücklich
grund zu der annahme dass die
impfkampagne erfolgreich sein wird wie
der tragischen langsamkeit zum trotz
jetzt doch etwas geschwindigkeit
aufnimmt dass wir tatsächlich eine
vielzahl von menschen die mehrzahl der
bevölkerung in der näheren zukunft
erreichen werden und wenn es soweit
kommt dass wir tatsächlich dann
bestimmte vergleichsweise geringer
prozentzahlen nicht impfen können dann
müssen wir uns überlegen was das
insgesamt bedeutet für die impfkampagne
aber auch für die wenn man so wie für
den bevölkerungs gesundheitsschutz
insgesamt da gibt es aber gute anzeichen
dafür dass der mit vergleichsweise
moderaten durchimpfungsraten ganz gut
leben können wir werden hier wie stets
auch natürlich nie eine
hundertprozentige sicherheit haben aber
das brauchen wir auch nicht und das wäre
eine schreckliche gesellschaft wenn wir
immer nur auf absolute sicherheit setzen
würden wenn wir restrisiken überhaupt
nicht akzeptierten wenn wir alltags
risiken restlos auszumerzen versuchten
das wäre in jedem falle einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft nicht
vorstellbar also es ist schon richtig
dass wir da auch bestimmte vielleicht
uns irrational erscheinende
entscheidungen akzeptieren solange das
eine relativ kleinen teil der
bevölkerung betrifft können wir das ohne
größere sorge akzeptieren jetzt kommen
wir zu dem impfpass teams nachweis sie
haben gerade schon in einem halbsatz
kritisch angemerkt dass ihnen quasi die
überlegungen wie das aussehen kann wie
auch die infrastruktur dahinter aussehen
kann wenn es sich um einen digitalen
impfnachweis handelt dass das ziemlich
spät kommt es gab aber schon von anfang
an stimmen die gesagt haben vorsicht
also alles was digital ist kann auch
gefälscht werden es kann gehackt werden
das kann kopiert werden und vor allem
wenn wir das irgendwo zentral ablegen
haben wir schwierigkeiten mit dem
datenschutz also es kann dann ja auch
tatsächlich können daten abhanden kommen
wie würden sie sich da positionieren
also ist tatsächlich diese dieser
digitale impfnachweis euro europaweit
eine gute idee
also ehrlicherweise würde ich mir
wünschen dass der digitale impfnachweis
weltweit kommt ich weiß dass die whu
auch daran arbeitet dass man eine
entsprechende digitale entsprechenden
nachweis funktion hat die sind auch
zuversichtlich dass sie das auch
wiederum mit hinreichender sicherheit
gestalten können wir arbeiten auf
nationaler ebene ja auch daran auch hier
gilt dass es natürlich
missbrauchsmöglichkeiten gibt aber wir
würden ja auch nicht sagen wir zahlen
keine steuern mehr oder schaffen das
ganze steuersystem ab weil es möglich
ist die finanzamt daten zu hacken
wir müssen doch irgendwie schauen dass
wir nicht von anfang an ganz ängstlich
nur auf mögliche fehlverwendung achten
sondern zunächst einmal überlegen wie
kann man den natürlich nach kräften
entgegen wirken aber andererseits auch
die chancen nutzen die mit so einem
instrument verbunden sind und die frau
bundeskanzlerin hat ganz nüchtern ja
auch darauf hingewiesen dass es neben
diesem zu entwickelnden digitalen ja im
moment auch erstmal den schlechten
papieren den pass gibt und auch der hat
einen nachweis funktion der ist
natürlich auch nicht vollständig
fälschungssicher nicht das ist ja auch
klar aber trotzdem haben wir damit eine
gewisse form von sicherheit und das muss
uns zur not dann erstmal genügen
ich habe jetzt hier noch mal eine
interessante wortmeldungen die sich
nicht mit dem impfen beschäftigt aber
ich denke vielleicht als mitglied des
ethikrates und als jurist können sie
auch was dazu sagen wo 81 schreibt ich
hätte gern eine solide begründung für
das erhalten der ausgangssperre
ich habe an sich nichts gegen regelungen
die sinnvoll sind aber diese macht im
vergleich zu erlaubten dingen keinen
sinn
ja das ist schwierig also es gibt
unterschiedliche studien dazu ich habe
einen kollegen in gießen der hat gerade
mit anderen zusammen etwa ein papier
veröffentlicht wo er auch das kritisch
unter die lupe nimmt ob das tatsächlich
etwas bringt es gibt studien aus dem
ausland wo nachgewiesen wird dass es
doch ein relativ hohen effekt hat
irgendwie leuchtet ja auch ein dass man
wenn man die
heute über nacht zu hause einsperren das
nicht völlig wirkungslos bleiben wird
aber ob dieser effekt der damit
verbunden ist in einem angemessenen
verhältnis steht zu der
freiheitsbeschränkung das ist in der tat
ausgesprochen zweifelhaft und deshalb
gibt es ja auch gerichtsentscheidungen
die da sehr kritisch mit umgegangen sind
in karlsruhe häufen sich die
verfassungsbeschwerden die gegen das
kürzer bevölkerungsschutz gesetz gegen
die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes jetzt erhoben
worden sind wir werden da wahrscheinlich
in absehbarer zeit passieren
ich habe ehrlicherweise gerade mit blick
auf die ausgangssperren einerseits schon
bedenken dass die verfassungskonformes
und auf der anderen seite scheint mir
das irgendwie so ein bisschen so ein
pappkamerad zu sein oder jedenfalls
etwas an dem sich ganz viele abarbeiten
während wir eine vielzahl von anderen
durchaus signifikanten vielleicht
signifikanter rennen beschränkung
insbesondere mit blick auf
berufsfreiheit etwa relativ klaglos
hinzunehmen bereit sind aber also wenn
wir uns überlegen was wir gerade mit den
den kindern in der schule in den
kindergärten machen mit den leuten die
seiten monaten ihren beruf nicht ausüben
können dann finde ich jetzt diese
ausgangssperre zwar in der konkreten
form schon bedenklich aber irgendwie
nicht
nicht so ein aufreger-thema wie es
teilweise gemacht wird professor queck
wir haben hier ein ausschnitt aus der
pressekonferenz mit dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten silber und der
bundeskanzlerin und meine kollegen haben
wir mal einen kleinen ausschnitt aus den
worten von herrn söder rausgeschnitten
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gerade noch
nicht worum es geht wir hören mal rein
wenn wir die geschwindigkeit erhöhen
da gab es heute eine debatte die war
schon sehr controllers muss man also die
bundesregierung hat meiner ansicht nach
dem richtigen weg denn wenn es um das
thema richtig für geimpfte gibbs das ist
eigentlich eine absurde debatte
jeder von uns hat grundrechte und die
geltende gelten für jeden in der
pandemie zweiten blick sagt wir müssen
ein rechte einschränken
zum schutz aller wenn aber das
robert-koch-institut sagt dass jemand
der sich die im stadt und der eine
zweitimpfung hat einen hohen maß an
schutz bietet dann glaube ich muss man
das respektieren und dann lässt sich
schlecht
vorstellen dass sie die gleichen
einschränkungen hatte jemand der sich
nicht kämpft hat jetzt gibt es den
zeitachse über die immer leben muss man
sich nicht impfen lassen
aber am ende ist es für mich ganz klar
da muss es dann eben mehr möglichkeiten
dem für diejenigen die gfc ist doch
völlig absurd dass ihr mann der zweimal
geimpft ist die gleichen tests verlegen
muss wie jemand der nicht geimpft ist
und dazu passt der kommentar von frank
dibowski hier auf youtube es ist auch
ein impfzwang wenn man ohne impfung
nichts mehr machen darf also wir sind
weiterhin in dieser in diesem großen
spannungsfeld hat herr müller
bürgermeister von berlin auch
angesprochen in der pressekonferenz dass
wir vielleicht eine zeit haben wo manche
schon raus gehen dürfen meint er manche
noch nicht raus gehen dürfen
manche rausgehen müssen also wie kann
man das argumentieren auch gerade mit
hinblick auf diese wortmeldung dass es
ein impfzwang ist ein indirekter dieses
argument kommt häufig wenn man ohne
impfung eben noch nicht machen darf was
andere mit dem von bereits machen dürfen
ja das ist eine interessante wortwahl
von herrn söder zu sagen das sei absurd
so etwas zu denken dass natürlich auch
ein bisschen so ein schienbein tritt
gegenüber den kolleginnen kollegen das
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger deutlich
so gesehen oder gesagt haben aber in der
sache ist da schon einiges dran wir
haben einen prinzipiellen
grundrechtsschutz den wir aus gründen
des infektionsschutz es teilweise
zeitweise begrenzt haben das heißt
bestimmte freiheiten sind uns genommen
worden unter der annahme dass wir
potenziell infektiös sind um zu
verhindern dass die pandemie sich noch
weiter ausbreite
und wenn jetzt für einzelne person
nachgewiesen werden kann dass sie gerade
diese infektiosität eben nicht haben
oder jedenfalls kaum haben so durch das
lka bestätigt hat dann ergibt es keinen
sinn und der infektionsschutz
gesichtspunkten sie weiterhin
beschränkungen zu unterwerfung und dann
ist das auch verfassungsrechtlich nicht
mehr akzeptabel
und wenn der zuschauer sagt dann ist das
ein impfzwang dann verkennt das glaube
ich etwas die grundsituation der zwang
besteht hier darin dass ich etwas nicht
machen darf und durch das impfen
verändert sich die voraussetzung unter
der mir dieser zwang aufgelegt wird
damit muss der 2
entfernt werden und dass damit ein
anreiz besteht sich impfen zu lassen ist
ja völlig klar
aber mit der gleichen argumentation
könnte ich auch sagen es ist ein
impfzwang dass die impfung ein
gesundheitsrisiko signifikant reduziert
das würde man ja auch nicht als einen
impfzwang überzeichnen soll es ist
natürlich etwas was anknüpft an dem
status des geimpft sein oder des genesen
salz oder auch das negativ getestet sein
dahinter steht aber die vorstellung dass
es eben einen unterschied macht ob
jemand potenziell infektiös ist oder ob
diese wahrscheinlichkeit sehr stark
abgesenkt ist sagt professor augsburg
professor für öffentliches recht und
mitglied des deutschen ethikrates ich
danke ihnen für ihre ausführungen und
die differenzierte darstellung heute
dankeschönabend so also wir haben gerade
gehört die pressekonferenz von
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die sich
geäußert hat nach einem treffen der
bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder dabei war
auch der oberbürgermeister von berlin
als vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und markus
söder als bayerischer ministerpräsident
und angela merkel hat sich geäußert zu
diesen treffen auch zu dem fortschreiten
der impfungen und wir haben ja noch mal
einen kurzen roten daraus wir haben in
vielen bundesländern jetzt bereits die
prioritäten gruppen 1 und 2 geimpft und
die prioritäten gruppe 3 ist geöffnet
und im großen und ganzen gehen wir davon
aus dass in der prioritäten gruppe 3 die
impfungen die erstimpfung im laufe des
monats mai stattfinden können so dass
wir dann spätestens je nachdem wie viele
impfdosen wir bekommen
ab juni aber ich sage nochmal spätestens
die priorisierungen aufgeben können und
es ist auch klar dass da wo als
zugangsberechtigung friseur click and
meet oder ähnliches schnelltests
erwartet werden geimpft und genesene
diese tests nicht beibringen müssen die
frage was gilt darüber hinaus und welche
grundrechte
haben diejenigen verlegen keine
infektionsgefahr rausgeht wieder die
haben wir heute ausführlich diskutiert
und die werden
das ergebnis dieser diskussion wird in
einer verordnung die dargelegt zum ja
also eine verordnung wird es geben
thomas reichert unser korrespondent im
hauptstadtstudio in berlin
die geht das ganz selbst weiter also es
kommt eine verordnung wann kommt die
jetzt ein zeitplan dafür ist schon klar
was da drin stehen wird oder ist das
alles noch mit fragezeichen versehen
das ist noch mit ganz vielen
fragezeichen versehen
weil ein solcher zeitplan den kennen wir
noch nicht und das ist sowieso so dass
man sich natürlich fragen kann dieses
professor opfer gegen gemacht hat warum
reden wir erst jetzt über solche dinge
die mit privilegien zu tun haben das
sind fragen die im grunde tatsächlich
schon wochen vorher bekannt sind jetzt
haben wir sozusagen die situation merkel
hat das ihr bundeskanzler merkt eben in
der pressekonferenz auch angesprochen
dass die zahl der dem fli führung
deutlich zunimmt sie sprach davon dass
im zweiten quartal jetzt 80 millionen
dosen von 50 millionen allein von
biontech das führt dazu dass wir alle
sparen der gesundheitsminister und
narrte setzen da sehr vorsichtig aber
die tendenz geht dahin dass wir offenbar
davon ausgehen können dass ab juni jeder
impfen kann weil dann die impf
priorisierung aufgehoben wird und dann
kommen eben diese ganzen fragen über die
es in der in dieser pressekonferenz
zentral gehen welche rechte hat er da
schon geimpft ist und wer welche rechte
hat deren nicht geben dann eben gerade
nicht das heißt wir können uns auf
muntere wochen das diskutierens
einstellen
naja diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
war wurde ihr gerade deswegen angerufen
im typisch merklichen konsensual
regierung steht dass sie versuchte diese
16 alphatiere möglich frühzeitig
einzubinden damit die diskussion um die
frage wie handelt man das denn jetzt
eigentlich mit den privilegien für
geimpfte dass man dem möglichst im
konsens löst das ist der erste schritt
das ist typisch merkel
der nächste schritt wird sein diese
diskussion dann im
den bundestag zu führen da wird es mit
sicherheit bundestagsdebatten geben die
bundesregierung hat da ist auf dem weg
der verordnung geschieht das recht das
auch selbst als sozusagen als exekutive
zu beschließen dazu braucht es kann
nicht erneut eine abstimmung im
bundestag die zuletzt bei der letzten
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
aber merkel steht noch mal ist so dass
sie da alle beteiligten und alle
wichtigen playern möglichst mit
einbinden soll die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz leben war
der erste schritt der nächste folgt
sogleich vermutlich dann mit den mit den
fraktionen im bundestag
jetzt habe ich ihnen hier ein paar
fragen an dich was diese impfstoff
priorisierung angeht das ist glaube ich
die meldungen die wir heute zumindest
verkünden können also die impfstoff
priorisierung soll aufgehoben werden
es wurde in aussicht gestellt in meidet
gruppe 3 dran kommen und ab juni kann
man so die bundeskanzlerin heute stand
jetzt jedem bundesbürger ein impfangebot
machen was nicht heißt dass alle im juni
geimpft werden können dieser möchte
wissen
die soll im juni aufgehoben werden gibt
es schon überlegungen inwiefern die art
der impfstoffe aufgeteilt werden soll
also das ist eine frage die immer wieder
kam kann ich mir aussuchen
womit ich danke impft werde nein das
kann man sich nicht das ist ganz klar
und das ist auch glaube ich
durchgängig in allen parteien und allen
fraktionen und auch in anh
landesregierungen konsens dass es eine
wahlmöglichkeit jenseits von
medizinischen indikationen in bezug auf
den impfstoff nicht geben kann und auch
nicht geben sollte weil es dann ja
sowieso schon bestimmte priorität oder
wunschlisten gibt das ist auch mit einem
auch für die zukunft so nicht absehbar
es ist er sozusagen die praktische seite
die dahintersteckt dadurch das biotec
weise mit abstand am meisten und am
zuverlässigsten bisher liefert gerade
zum beispiel im gegensatz zu astrazeneca
das bislang sei dem versprechen oder
seine liefert versprechen nicht
eingehalten
hat ist es die pure masse die dafür
sorgt dass vermutlich die überwiegende
mehrheit den bei antec impfstoff
bekommen wird und und es sozusagen
wenige von astrazeneca gibt aber eine
wunschliste mit dem man ins impfzentrum
geht die wird es nicht geben ich sehe
nirgendwo polit relevante politische
akteure die dafür eintreten würden dass
das möglich sein soll also keine
speisekarte die man dann bekommt das
hätten sie heute gern abschlussfrage von
julius noch mal ganz konkret heißt das
dass ab juni jeder und jede unabhängig
vom geburtsjahr geimpft werden kann
die aufhebung der inthronisierung heißt
genau das wobei jetzt kommt wie immer
das große die große eile haben einen
aber muss es immer geben
vor allem in dieser pandemie und vor
allem wenn es um das pandemien
management geht ja gibt es leider auch
diesmal bei merkel und auch personen
gesundheitsminister sparen die
einschränkung gemacht haben dass die
aufhebung der improvisieren im juni
nicht bedeutet dass genug impfstoff da
ist damit jeder auch im juni auch schon
geimpft werden kann dass ihm versprechen
merkel wurde explizit von einer kollegin
danach gefragt das versprechen geht nach
wie vor erst zum 21 september kurz vor
der bundestagswahl gut zum ende des
sommers verspricht merkel das wirklich
jeden in deutschland ein ins angebot
gemacht werden kann
aber die aufhebung der im frühjahr
priorisierung die soll es schon im juni
geben
das ist also das was wir heute als ja
zumindest ankündigung der
bundesregierung weiterleiten können
vielen dank thomas wird seine
erklärungen und ganz wichtig ist ja für
uns noch mal zu schauen wie die
impfzahlen eigentlich aussehen denn das
ist natürlich in dieser pandemie mit ein
ganz wichtiges parameter je mehr
menschen geimpft sind desto schneller
kann das gehen mit den öffnungen wir
haben die aktuellen zahlen mal für uns
zusammengeführt zusammengefasst
in deutschland haben zuletzt immer mehr
menschen die anti corona spritze
bekommen
so sind mittlerweile knapp 19 eineinhalb
millionen menschen mindestens einmal
geimpft worden das sind 23,4 prozent
knapp sechs millionen menschen sind zwei
mal und damit vollständig geimpft 7,2
prozent zum vergleich in den usa sind
mehr als 27 prozent vollständig geimpft
in großbritannien sind es 17,8 in
frankreich 7,9 auffällig dass im tempo
ist hierzulande zuletzt rasant
angestiegen auch weil hausarztpraxen
seit anfang april gegen korona impfen
dürfen
zuletzt gab es im schnitt rund 485.000
impfungen anfang des monats waren es nur
etwas über 300.000 doch zwischen den
bundesländern gibt es unterschiede
nicht zuletzt wegen der verteilung
während im saarland rund jeder vierte
mindestens eine erste impfung bekommen
hat sind es in hessen nur 21,5 so und
alle fragen zu den impfungen kann uns
jetzt beantworten ev hungers direktorin
des instituts für allgemeinmedizin der
universitätsmedizin göttingen
entschuldigung und mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission am rki schöne
und an france ich würde ganz gerne
einfach da weiter machen wo wir gerade
aufgehört haben nämlich bei der frage
wer kann denn jetzt eventuell diese
impfstoffe kriegen also nah kann ab juni
quasi jeder und jede sich eine impfung
holen wenn das genug impfstoff gibt und
dort gleich eine anfrage von patrick auf
youtube der sagte ich dachte unter 60
bekommt man auf jeden fall nicht
astrazeneca also ich merke wir haben
immer noch verwirrung was jetzt diesen
impfstoff der universität oxford
schrägstrich astrazeneca angeht wie
sieht's so aus er bringt gehört wird man
das nicht geplant ist dass ich menschen
im schlaf aussuchen können
das heißt dann dass ihnen die noch keine
60 sind eine marinade impfstoff
angeboten werden wird also der hörer
dennoch keine sechzig ist ja bekommt
dann kein angebot für akademiker sondern
für einen anderen impfstoff dh im
endeffekt dass mein kollege sagte thomas
reiter in berlin ist es relativ
wahrscheinlich dass man unter 60 mit
biontech oder vielleicht mit moderner
geimpft
das höchstwahrscheinlich es sei denn man
wünscht sich ausdrücklich den anderen
impfstoff weil man entweder da schneller
drankommen kann oder aber weil man den
bayer-manager etwas höheren schule die
nach erstimpfung mitnehmen möchte wobei
das ja auch ein mittelwert über eine
größere geholt und auch dort gleich eine
anschlussfrage von niklas troll
minderjährige sind ab juni aber auch
weiterhin nicht ins berechtigt richtig
minderjährige stimmt nicht abwechselt
sind also ist der biotech impfstoff zu
benutzen
die altersgruppe der 16 bis 18 jährigen
könnte man wenn die regierung
entsprechend aufgegeben wird mit
bayonetta kämpfen die anderen hilft
gelassenen impfstoffe sind bisher eben
erst abgelaufen
so jetzt habe ich warum probieren bei
kindern aber da hat man auch keine
ergebnisse
jetzt habe ich wie das fast immer der
fall ist wenn wir über impfungen reden
wieder kommentatorinnen im chat die sich
sorgen machen was die sicherheit angeht
die sagen normalerweise wird ein
impfstoff drei bis fünf jahre getestet
was ist mit langzeit wirkungen
ich weiß überhaupt nicht was da drin ist
ich hatte immer schon ein herausgesucht
jörg rau war das der hand geschrieben
auf der impfstoff ist nicht zuende
erforscht und keiner will für die
impfschäden haften
seine schlussfolgerung daraus er möchte
sich nicht impfen lassen was können sie
diesen zuhörerinnen unter zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern sagen
keiner wird für die im krisenhaften dem
nicht wie für alle öffentlich
empfohlenen impfungen haftet für schäden
war der coup mit info das land
beziehungsweise der bund das heißt da
gibt es sehr wohl eine haftung wenn bei
einem gemischten wirklichen schaden
auftritt und das gilt für alle stoffe
und andere menschen die sich dagegen im
zu lassen nicht möglich auch dann wenn
jemand auf eigenen wunsch im alter von
unter 60 doch den astra zeneca impfstoff
bekommen warum müssen sie denn die
hessen öffentlich empfohlene impfungen
eine eine ordnungsstrafe tun das ist ja
für die unternehmen relativ komfortabel
oder
jetzt die diskussion wo ich kein
absoluter experte bin normalerweise im
stoffe keine produkte mit denen viele
gemacht werden können das dürfte im
moment sehr anders aussehen aber
umgekehrt ist es eben auch eine sehr
hohe haftungsfrage für seltene
ereignisse
ich denke grundsätzlich ist es auch um
das vertrauen der bevölkerung in
impfungen zu stärken und damit es
hinterher keine langwierigen
auseinandersetzungen da gibt existiert
diese regelung sehr lange aber dann ist
ja genau diese frage des vertrauens weil
die immer wieder diese fragen haben
können sich vielleicht noch was tust du
dazu sagen dass diese impfstoffe jetzt
von von ihnen von der ständigen
impfkommission auch so schnell empfohlen
wurden ja auch schnell zugelassen worden
und nicht weniger erforscht als andere
impfstoffe weil sie noch nicht so lange
da sind während eine ganze einmalige
situation nämlich das mit sehr viel geld
und mit einem weltweiten einsatz von
experten schnell impfstoffe entwickelt
wurden
aber auch eine von der liga bei der sehr
viele menschen bereit waren also im stop
studien teilzunehmen und sehr viele
menschen geimpft wurden und trotzdem
angesichts schon infektionsdruck sehr
schnell fälle auftraten
das heißt die anzahl personen mit denen
dieser impfstoff zulassungsstudien
gemacht worden ist nicht geringer
sondern eher höher als bei anderen
impfstoffen das einzige aber bleibt die
sache mit der nachbeobachtungszeit die
ist in der tat kürzer als man das bei
anderen impfstoffen zum teil hat jetzt
aber wo kann ich das irgendwie stoffen
ebenso kundschaft immer frühzeitig
auftreten sodass nach opas zeiten von
jetzt knapp einem jahr da doch schon
eine erhebliche sicherheit geben aber
vielmehr die weltweite zahl der eine
anschlussfrage zu diesem jahr dieser
vertrauens geschichte von arosa rassist
ist die empfehlung der stiko bezüglich
astrazeneca rein wissenschaftlich oder
spielen da so zur gesellschaftliche
effekte mit rein klammer auf man will
das vertrauen in die kontrolle der
impfstoffe erwecken
zugeben dass ich sie frage sich genau
verstehen
ja ich kann ja mal den hintergrund
erläutern der hintergrund ist einerseits
epidemiologie der erkrankung als die
anzahl der infektionen die auftritt die
anzahl der menschen die krank werden ist
schwer krank werden wir eine abschätzung
den einzelnen darstellt desweiteren dort
ein werk das über die wirksamkeit für
die schutzwirkung der impfstoffe bekannt
ist und das was über mögliche
nebenwirkungen bekannt werden also ich
verstehe die die frage so dass der
zuschauer meint also haben sie sich
wirklich nur auf quasi die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse
verlassen oder wollten sie quasi zeigen
okay wir wir kontrollieren das wir
nehmen das ernst und deswegen machen wir
quasi diese empfehlung dass astrazeneca
für unter 60 jährige nicht mehr verimpft
werden soll wenn nicht auf
ausdrücklichen wunsch und mit absprache
des arztes weil so verstehe ich den
zuschauer im grunde das risiko gar nicht
so hoch wäre aber trotzdem versucht man
was zu tun um zu sagen okay wir
kontrollieren wir haben ein auge drauf
wieder kein widerspruch dass fertig und
wissenschaftlich wenn man das bedeutet
einerseits einer schweren erkrankung und
andererseits das erschweren den stoff
nebenwirkungen oder in beiden fällen
eben auch der tod durch gut da der durch
eine impfstoff nächsten song contest
gegeneinander abwägt und in der tat dass
wir im moment noch jeden impfstoff
brauchen können um die anderen wieder
unter kontrolle zu bekommen
dass auch jüngere menschen das
verhältnis ich sehr deutlich höher ist
das risiko an einer schweren impfstoff
nebenwirkung zu erkranken
es ist aber der nutzen ist und der
relativen nutzen wenn man das vergleicht
ist für ältere menschen noch mal sehr
deutlich höher als für jüngere einfach
weil die älteren seltenheit der
nebenwirkungen haben und sehr sehr viel
hall stankovic schwer erkranken als das
bei einem jungen menschen der fall ist
jetzt gibt es eine ganz konkrete frage
die auch so halb beantwortet wurde in
der pressekonferenz da hat die bundes
kanzlerin gesagt also man wird quasi
menschen die eine infektion hinter sich
haben also genesen und dann eine impfung
bekommen haben gleichstellen mitmenschen
die vollständig geimpft sind
und thomas davis fragt sich jetzt aber
ist es gefährlich sich impfen zu lassen
denn man bereits eine infektion hinter
sich hatte das empfehlung lautet wer
eine bekannte infektion hatte es gibt ja
immer auch menschen die ihrer kuppel
infektionen vielleicht gar nicht erkannt
haben weil sie nicht symptomatisch war
es ist nicht gefährlich das risiko einer
impfreaktion sie habe eine harte
reaktion ist vielleicht etwas aber wer
besondere dass nach einer erkrankung
eine impfung ausreicht
der stoff noch knapp ist soll das dann
erst einmal ausreichend irgendwann
werden wir uns wahrscheinlich alle acht
zu lassen setzen dass ich das auch
schwer krank waren keine konkreten
planungen in sicht aufgrund der
mutationen oder ich denke sicherlich
aufgrund der mutation vielleicht auch
aufgrund einer abnehmenden immunität
dass weidmann in der tat noch nicht ab
so braucht man längere
nachbeobachtungszeit man aber der druck
der eben durch die 100 lohnen entsteht
weist darauf hin dass er sich bei der
gruppe in puncto aufgebaut dass man dann
immer mal wieder den impfstoff etwas
verändert erneut anwenden
frau merkel hat auch gerade den
impfstoff aus russland sputnik wie sie
hatten als sputnik 5 oder
vorbezeichneten sputnik wie ist die
richtige aussprache angesprochen und hat
gesagt es dauert noch so ein bisschen
können sie da vielleicht mal was darüber
sagen wie da der stand der dinge ist und
woran das eventuell geraten weil ich mit
der sputnik wie auch immer es ist einer
von drei stoffen der im moment in der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur in
einem ständigen begutachtungsverfahren
ist der sogenannte rowling
das ist noch kein zulassungsverfahren
aber das ist ein der zu lassen und
vorgeschaltete verfahren weil der
ehemals ich eben alle daten die
hersteller dazu
wir stellen wollten und könnten zumal
geben lässt und dann guckt ob die
voraussetzungen für ein
zulassungsverfahren überhaupt schon
gegeben sind und das ist bei den
sputniks schon länger der fall und
erweckt den anschein als ob es die
vorangingen
das bezieht sich ja da das kann viele
verschiedene gründe haben
da geht es ja nicht wirksamkeit des
impfstoffes studien da geht es auch um
die stabilität unterschiedlicher
produktionschargen dass es überhaupt ein
produktionsbedingungen und da scheint
eben bei diesem impfstoff noch einiges
im klaren zu sein
ja was ich da nicht schneller geht
einzelheiten dazu bin ich vor das sind
ja sämtliche vertrauliche daten ich habe
noch zwei fragen die ich ihnen gerne
weiterreichen würde einmal von des night
warum muss man sich überhaupt noch mal
impfen lassen wenn man genießen ist ja
auch wenn man kann man ja auch wenn das
sehr selten und noch viel seltener in
schwerer form passiert ein zweites mal
erkranken und ich wohl so dass auch nach
einer erkrankung eine die körper wieder
absinken und sagte dann tatsächlich ein
schlechteres letztens noch sagen ist
bekannt umgekehrt ist es so wenn man
sich nach einer erkrankung im zuletzt
dann steigen die frau kann meistro an
und es ist davon auszugehen dass dann
das system eben auch so nachhaltig
trainiert ist das inzwischen kontakt
auch erklärt das prinzip eine
sicherheitsmaßnahme dann habe ich noch
eine frage von taifun der sich sorgen
macht dass es geht so ein bisschen in
die richtung die wir gerade schon hatten
langzeitschäden was passiert wenn in 20
jahren festgestellt wird dass die
impfungen zu krebs geführt hat frage an
die medizinerin ist das überhaupt
möglich
wer sagt eigentlich sehr äußerst
unwahrscheinlich das heißt also
eigentlich nie aber wir wären keine info
bekannte nicht so krebs wird ich wüsste
nicht wie das hier der fall sein sollte
also das risiko halte ich für
ausgeschlossen
ok dann habe ich hier noch eine andere
gründe aus
gegen krebs bekommen kann ja nur
kleinkinder erwarten nicht zugehört aber
wenn das passieren könnte und man das
nachweisen könnte was sie sagen in der
medizin soll man nie nie sagen dann wäre
das tatsächlich ein fall wo dann
irgendwann so eine haftung greifen würde
viel konjunktiv auf den impfstoff zurück
schülerin letzten jahr vielleicht
ergänzen wenn der impfstoff das macht
und impfstoffe das machen wir wieder im
moment auch haben das ist eine komische
erkrankung das erst recht tun dann
werden sie also vermutlich immer noch
mit der impfung auf der sicheren seite
und dann habe ich noch eine reihe
äußerst unwahrscheinlich habe ich noch
eine frage die sich noch mal richtig an
diese impfstoffe verschiedene impfstoffe
richtet sie den kommentar gerade nicht
mehr aber ich habe mir die frage gemerkt
wie sehen eigentlich die unterschiede
aus zwischen den impfstoffen die wir
gerade in deutschland haben die
unterschiede aus wir haben es ist ein
unterschiedliches impfstoff verfahren
wobei alle vier impfstoffe die in
deutschland zugelassen sind oder die
drei die wir tatsächlich hier haben
letztlich das stückchen virus mutieren
und da wirklich selten antikörper
erzeugen
aber die beiden impfstoffe von
einerseits bajonett und andererseits des
amerikanischen herstellers moderner fast
identisch in einem ist ein planer
stabilisator zusätzlich drin
auf dem so genannten m rna impfstoffe
seitdem also ein mit ethisch
hergestellte stückchen des genetischen
codes nicht wie das weitergehen nicht
das was im zellkern ist sondern diesen
tag hin gespritzt wird und bei dem
impfstoff von astrazeneca wie auch
konnten ansonsten ist ein stückchen
genetische kochrezept gentechnisch auf
ein nichts mehr vermehrungsfähigen
anderen virus draufgepackt der
sogenannte vector was ihr alle kodieren
dasselbe stückchen spike protein aber
die trägersubstanz sich im sinne des
anlegers landung
so schreibt abschlussfrage die haben wir
auch immer noch einen spitzenwert von
grippeimpfungen geht in dem zusammenhang
ich freue mich wirklich alle angeklagten
ja das ist interessant tatsächlich aber
auf der anderen seite ist es ja auch gut
werden wir tatsächlich menschen wie sie
haben die sich bemühen alle details zu
beantworten um eine informierte
öffentlichkeit herzustellen
letzte frage wichtig letzte frage auch
schon fast ein klassiker den können wir
hier wenn es sinnvoll geht immer schon
stellen normalerweise so fragt man das
schnell ist immer wie geht es jetzt
weiter
die klassiker frage bei münchen ist
haben sie sich schon impfen lassen und
wenn ja womit ich bin sehr früh im jahr
und geimpft worden mit bajonett noch gar
keinen anderen gab und zwar deswegen
weil ich eben nicht nur haus erst
richtig bin sondern auch als ärztliche
leiterin des lokal im zentrum hier also
schon im januar bisschen fliege heim
gefahren bin und dort selbst nicht
geimpft aber im flieger aufgeklärt habe
so dass ich im kontext legen auch wert
geben geworden bin wie die anderen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
zentrum auch dann danke ich ihnen frau
aus dass sie heute abend für uns da
waren und für die wissenschaft
gesprochen haben und für die ständige
impfkommission ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen abend und bedanke mich bei
euch
er wurde gerade aus sorge sagt ich soll
was mit shisha bar auch sagen vermutlich
habt ihr euch wieder sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass die aufgemacht werden
ich weiß wir werden alle sehr viele
köpfe rauchen ist damit nur wenn wir
wieder eine shisha bars dürfen
bis dahin lassen wir die köpfe rauchen
die wir das einrichten können ich grüße
euch und eure freunde und sage bis zum
nächsten stream ist auf jeden fall
wahrscheinlich schon gebauten wieder für
euch da lasst uns ein like und ein abo
da holt euch die zdf heute ab da kriegt
ja auch eine push mitteilungen der
online gehen oder macht diese dinge ling
glocke in youtube an
und wenn euch das team gefallen hat dann
teilt doch mal verrückte sache in diesem
sinne sage ich einen schönen abend noch
bis bald und tschüss